this is like a lot more than usual is
left unfinished and there's not
necessarily reconciliation with a lot of
the things that were going on pledge and
Barry and iris and separation and the
mirror verse and so yeah there's there's
a lot that's left unfinished
the real iris is out there somewhere and
thank you so much for taking time out of
your social distancing it's incredibly
busy schedule yeah exactly
do chat about the flash um we definitely
have a first this year we're ending the
season on 6:19 so you guys are a couple
episodes shy of what you were originally
planning on doing how are you feeling
about that and and where this season is
gonna leave off yeah I mean obviously
it's a little disappointing the writers
were working really hard to work towards
what they had planned for 622 and it's
still a good cliffhanger I mean
thankfully our episodes generally have
built in cliffhangers especially as we
get closer to the end of the year so I
mean I know some fans will be
disappointed but it still serves as a
good cliffhanger and I I mean everyone
has a right to be a little disappointed
right now but the whole world is kind of
being flipped on its head so I think we
can all accept that this is the reality
and sadly we just didn't get to do as
many episodes do you feel like of the
bits and pieces that you were able to
film from the future episodes you're
gonna be able to use those in the next
season or do you think that the writers
are gonna have you guys just start over
as a clean slate no I would have to
imagine that I mean with the way things
are gonna be left off we're gonna still
need a lot of these pieces to finish
what we were doing so I think what would
have served this episode six 20 21 and
22 maybe they won't do those storylines
in their entirety at the beginning of
season 7 but where I would imagine we're
gonna finish we're gonna do kind of
condensed versions of those three
episodes before we continue
yeah and that's me speculating I haven't
necessarily had that conversation with
the writers of course everyone's still
figuring this out as you were going
along we have Jefferson's left this
season the penultimate and now 619 which
is the finale
what can you tease for the fans out
there you mentioned that we're getting a
cliffhanger some fans might not be super
thrilled is that just because not
everything was wrapped up with a bow
yeah no there's definitely no bow this
year and I mean generally and we tend to
finish the season with a little bit of
you know we like that element but this
is like a lot more than usual is left
unfinished and there's not necessarily
reconciliation with a lot of the things
that we're going on with flash and Barry
and iris and separation and mirror verse
and so yeah there's there's a lot that's
left unfinished but as we saw in the
last episode Barry had started to catch
on in 617 that he finally was having
this epiphany that he hadn't been living
with his wife and something was going on
and he shares his concerns with Ciccio
and the team starts to catch on to
what's been happening that maybe iris is
somewhere else and we'll see to that
start to do a little bit more in 18 and
things will definitely still come to a
head and 619 but there's not as it
doesn't get resolved as much as we
probably like it to
I was so excited to see that Barry knew
that this was not his wife he was
putting the pieces together I really
think that speaks volumes for for them
as a couple what was your reaction when
you found out that he was gonna guess
that that wasn't her yeah no I was glad
that we finally got there I mean it took
a while to get there but I I think you
know like there was even a scene that
Barry had with mirror iris where you
know iris is a strong willed character
and is just as strong and stronger than
Barry in a lot of ways and they can't
they had that they came head to head
with her saying like I am growing I'm
changing as a person in Barry's like
you're right and I have to love you
regardless so like that was a very iris
thing still so I think that was what I
was able to use
you just believe that he wasn't figuring
it out right away because there was all
these things going on with him losing
his speed and thawne being back and and
trying to build obviously he loves his
wife and believe that [ __ ] and
understand that she is gonna change and
grow as a person they need to be able to
love each other for each other
regardless so I could believe that it
took him so long to figure it out but it
was a relief when he finally all these
things started to click in the place and
he was kind of remembering some of these
strange occurrences that happened like
the pancakes and the bottle smashing on
the head and all these things that
really aren't that weird but when you
add them all up it started it was cool
to see how they I loved the scene that
Danny and I had were at the West house
where she comes and is like madman crime
scene and we had a lot of fun with that
so yeah it was it was a relief when we
finally realized let's talk about Barry
this season he's been through every
iteration of learning different powers
losing his powers the Speed Force all of
this stuff now we're really seeing what
is the flash without his speed what does
that been like for you and and could we
hold out hope that the flash will still
be the flash yeah I would say it's safe
to hold out hope that we're gonna figure
this thing out and whether it's an
artificial Speed Force restoring the
actual speed for us I've gotta imagine
that we're gonna figure it out it for me
it's been fun I mean it's just different
and at times I haven't even worn the
suit for entire episodes which like I
when you watch it like weave me and LA
watch this pass up so together I was
weird I wasn't in the suit once like as
a viewer you're like man but when I'm
shooting that was a plus for sure while
filming and it's just different again
it's a lot more Barry I mean though it's
fun at times and hard at times that just
like to play Barry so discouraged
constantly and
it's definitely been he's been kind of
an all-time low as far as this
confidence for a lot of the second half
of the season so that's been weird to
play and different but you know always
nice to change things oh well speaking
of the suit we've had six seasons we've
seen quite the evolution we've gone from
maroon to the bright red we've seen the
ring come into play what is still on
your flash suit bucket list what would
you like to see gold boots little wings
well we have you know they're like
lightning at the top of the red boots
that are kind of like the wing slash
lightning at the top but no I want to
see like that's really know if we're
missing for it to be pretty much the
complete comic book look it's the suit
that we have now essentially but with
like boots to match the belt and I feel
like we're there do you think berry can
pull off gold boots I know
let me rephrase can grant pull off
absolutely absolutely we have six
seasons under your cowl at this point
how much longer do you see yourself
playing the flash listen I mean it's I
may never have a job this cool again
that people that this many people
actually tune in to watch so I'm not
gonna take it for granted I you know I
don't know I could I was talking to
Michael Rosenbaum the other day and it's
like to go as many seasons as they did
with Smallville like nobody gets to do
that that's always been something that I
thought would be really cool to
accomplish it's not just my decision
obviously has a lot to do with the
viewers and the network and I guess
we'll just have to wait and see but I
can we I can definitely see myself doing
more than just the one that I have left
on this current contract you know it's
seven is it for most of the cast
actually but I think it'd be great if we
could continue after that
definitely do you still have anything
that's on your on your flash dream list
anything that you like to accomplish a
fun episode more musicals you know I
don't know I think I have we ever need
to do a full-blown years ago again but
like little things like the karaoke
scene that we did that was that season
one or two that was season one one yeah
like that you know it's fun like you
know sing again within our world that
were it's not like a dream we're all
that like musicals feel like I would
definitely be open to singing again on
the show if it was like in that capacity
drunk berry again because you yelling
it's still my favorite scene of all
those that was fun
I think I had even more fun with the
episode danielle Panabaker directed
where with poor berry pretended to be
drunk on the stage of the auction for
like be the distraction I had like the
champagne yeah I mean I you know but the
fun stuff would definitely be at the top
of my wish list as far as you know just
seeing the team not be team flash like
kind of do other fun things and I know
Eric Wallace has a lot of things left on
his wish list for flash things so I
would have to leave it to him for you
know I'm game for whatever Eric wants to
do mm-hmm
have you been able to connect it all
with any of your flash family while
you've been social distancing yeah I
mean I've pretty much every at least
every few days once we check in with you
know everybody we're all kind of
checking on each other later today
actually me and Carlos and Jesse and
Andy Mientus Pied Piper are doing up a
game night thing benefiting the Actors
Fund so that would be fun we get to all
be on sue them together play some games
but yeah we're all you know checking in
on each other everyone's pretty much in
the same boat just like at home and you
know how you doing what are you doing
like I'm good but bored not doing
anything
all right cool check in next week I'm
watching the flash we got yeah
you know there's not much going on right
now you know videos shaved some days I'm
really today I was very reluctant it was
a cardio like jumping next day and I was
like I think I'm gonna be stuck in
traffic today but there aren't really
excuses for missing anything right now
so yeah they're working out a lot I've
been playing guitar trying to like learn
how to play guitar and you know just do
a couple things that aren't just playing
PlayStation all day long which I could
do if I let myself so have you done been
doing anything you know we've been
repeating things that we know we love
like we already did all of the office
really early on
we're now on season three of new girl
we're redoing new girl which like I knew
I loved forgot how like laugh out loud
funny that show is yeah and we're doing
like tiny house nation do you know this
show is it about like and it's really
it's made me like we early on like
countably did a spring cleaning and
pared down on a lot of our stuff and
pared down it's a phrase I got from tiny
house nation and now we're like even
more inspired to like we don't need
everything we have like we need to pare
down more and get rid of our clothes
people need this stuff but we don't so
we're get that vibe for watching the
Marie Kondo show but you're like tiny
huh yeah I haven't actually watched that
yet so I'm sure if I watch did I do all
about like organizing my closet fold
everything in your closet
[Music]